[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
versailles face à nice un club de
nationale 2 face à un club de ligue 1 le
coup d'envoi a été donné à 21h ce mardi
1er mars à les supporters yvelinois ont
suivi cette demi finale de coupe de
france de football de près la première
mi temps ils sont accrochés jusqu'au
bout les 00 deuxième mi temps je pense
que la fatigue s'est accumulée
malheureusement bat la différence de
niveau s'est fait ressentir et on s'est
pris les deux buts mais bon on saura que
les honneurs dans ce pub situé rue
colbert à versailles ils étaient près de
150 à être venus soutenir l'équipe
locale soria lesquels pas mal de monde
une belle ambiance c'est sûr que c'est
pas un mardi ordinaire comme d'habitude
donc c'est toujours un gros plus les
bars et les pubs versailles est une
alternative pour ceux qui n'ont pas pu
faire le déplacement à nice ceux qui
n'ont pas pu suivre la rencontre 2 chez
eux ou encore pour ceux qui voulaient
tout simplement profiter de l'ambiance
versailles m
on est derrière notre club donc c'est là
derrière notre ville c'est assez rare
donc c'était assez puissant sané super
plaisir il y avait une super mieux en
bas bon on n'a pas gagné mais on a vibré
ce soir match sympa on a passé un bon
moment en tout cas je suis contente
quand même fort
était cool que vers sagan le fc
versailles et le cinquième club de
nationale 2 accéder aux demi finales de
coupe de france de football un parcours
historique pour le club même s'il aurait
aimé voir un but tous s'accordent à
saluer cette performance inédite ont
cédé leur parcours ils ont fait plaisir
ce soir ils sortent franchement ils ont
fait un beau match peut pas leur en
vouloir et alors merci pour nous avoir
fait vivre c'est beau parcours on perd
2-0 mais ils ont vraiment pas à rougir
je suis un peu triste mais vraiment je
suis plus fier parce que ils ont fait le
taff n'ont pas démérité je pense qu'il
doit être fier de ses coûts le voir que
larissa y arriva
à l'as du volant si le club versailles
et s'est incliné 2 0 face à nice
certains supporters ils croient déjà
pour l'année prochaine c'est
encourageant en plus le club monte en
puissance donc on y croit on se dit que
quand même chaque année c'est pas la
première fois il ya deux trois ans on va
aux journées aussi monter on a aussi
bien joué en coupe de france j'espère
que vous allez avoir les prochaines
années croît en attendant les supporters
du fc versailles espère voir le club de
nationale 2 monter d'une division en
national